[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est pas le lieu où il où il y a eu
un banquet mais par contre c'est
l'endroit où on a rejeté ce qui ce qui
provient de ce banquet donc ça se voit
parce que il y a un gros tados que vous
avez ici qui sont des osements animaux
alors il a l'air gros comme ça mais
c'est un petit échantillon de tout ce
qui est sorti de cette de cette fosse he
parce que c'est une fosse remplie par
des par des ossems là on arrive enfin si
j'ose dire au bout de au bout du
prélèvement des EOS parce que c'était
très long à fouiller que c'était un
sacré casse tête imaginez un M cadeau de
de d'ossement animaux et ben vous voilà
vous avez à peu près ce qu'on vécu les
fouillons pendant ces 3 semaines dès
qu'on donnait un coup de truelle c'était
10 eau différents qui sortaient pas tout
de la même bête pas tout pas tous de la
même espèce donc voilà c'était assez
compliqué j'imagine que ça avance
doucement ça avance très euh très
minutieusement en tout cas parce qu'on
est obligé il faut ne rien rater il faut
pouvoir observer les connexions
anatomiques des EOS euh qui sont encore
liés les uns aux autres parce que ça
donne des informations là d'ailleurs je
crois que ce sont des connexion qu'il
est en train de prélever oui un bout de
cheville de bœuf ici qui est bien
visible et la suite peut-être qu' part
par là-bas faut que je faut que je
continue à creuser pour savoir mais ici
vous avez un bout de crâne de de cochon
qui s'est posé dessus avec des petits
eau de cochons qui sont tombés dans le
crâne du cheval donc du coup il va
falloir que je fouille ça très
précautionneusement et il y a les dents
aussi qui à fleur
làoup pas si vous les voyez bien les
petits espèces de petits carrés blanc là
ça c'est les dents supérieures du
cochon par exemple celui-ci c'est un
individu adulte parce que les os sont
bien soudés entre eux à côté par contre
c'est un individu qui est plus juvénile
parce que cet OS là qui est le
zigomatique ne s'est pas souderé au
temporal qui est derrière au maxillaire
qui est derrière donc je sais que cet
individu cet individu là pardon est
assez jeune derrière vous avez une une
cheville osseuse de de
bœuf je crois que vous avez une ver de
bœuf aussi Qui est qui est tombé là en
fait les OSM en connexion c'est
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
c'est des des des pattes en l'occurrence
qui ont été rejeté dans ce contexte
alors que les chairres étaient encore
présentes donc ça veut dire que c'est
pas quelque chose qui s'est décomposé
ailleurs et qu'on ajouté là ensuite ça
induit une simultanéité presque des
événements qu'il est vraiment important
d'observer parce que ça veut dire que là
le dépôt qui a été fait il suit
directement la pratique alimentaire le
l'événement en tout cas dont on va
essayer de comprendre la nature en fait
moi j'ide Quentin le temps que Mathilde
fasse les trucs quand elle finit je
rejoins avec eu à la TR ok bah reste
là-bas je pense c'est bien parce que
vous avez une zone qui est assez grande
à vous à vous décaper et tout seul ça va
être un peu le désespoir regardez si
vous avez les
sachets c'est pour mieux comprendre ce
monument qu'on a commencé à fouiller ici
ce monument du cuétis du cutis c'est le
gros monument que vous avez là ouais et
c'est un monument qui à la base a été
fouillé au début du 20e siècle par la
Société des Sciences de ce mur en
noosois une société savante locale et
donc c'est c'est à cette société savante
qu'on doit tout le dégagement du centre
monumental d'Alesia au début du 20e
siècle quand je dis centre monumental
d'Alesia c'est le centre monumental
d'époque impériale à alisia puisque
par-dessus la ville gaouoise il y a la
ville romaine et que les fots du 20e
siècle se sont arrêtés sur les vestiges
les plus récents de de l'époque
impériale sans aller explorer
systématiquement les niveaux plus
anciens ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui en
archéologie en fait quand on rencontre
des structures mettons du 2e siècle on
en démonte des parties en tout cas on
démonte les niveaux de sol et on
s'enfonce dans les niveaux de sol pour
remonter le temps puisque on construit
toujours sur ses propres déblet et on
s'élève toujours sur ses propres ramblet
c'est pour ça que dans des grandes
villes comme Lyon par exemple vous avez
des stratigraphies qui sont énormes donc
ce monument du cuétis il a été il a été
dégagé au début du 20e siècle et dès
qu'il a été dégagé il a il a retenu
l'attention quand même des des
contemporains parce que si on se promène
sur sur ce site visitable on se rend
facilement compte que c'est le mieux
conservé parce que il est un peu
encaissé dans la pente et donc cet
encaissement partiel la laa protégé en
plus il y a une partie du monument qui
est souterraine si vous vous approchez
vous verrez qu'il y a une crypte qui est
creusée dans le rock et qui est
accessible par une grande baie une
grande baie ininttrée donc tout ça sont
des choses qui ont été forcément rblayé
plus vite que le reste au moment où la
ville a été abandonné et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le monument nous est
parvenu dans un meilleur état de
conservation dans la salle souterraine
qui est là-bas justement a été trouvé un
assemblage de d'objets métalliques assez
variés et dans cet assemblage d'objets
métalliqu il y avait un vase en bronze
qui portait une dédicace sur le col qui
dit à ucuetis et Bergusia en fait c'est
une offrande c'est un vase un vase votif
et c'est deux divinités des divinités
plutôt celtiques et quand on trouve ce
vase dédié à UTIs on fait le lien avec
une inscription qui a été trouvé en 1836
au niveau du centre monumental une
inscription en galol latin donc c'est du
Gaulois écrit en latin qui dit que à
alisia la corporation des artisans
métallurgistes a offert un monument à
leur divinité de corporation qui est
UTIs donc c'est une inscription très
célèbre ne serait-ce que parce que la
dernière ligne mentionne le nom d'alisia
in alisia donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
appelé ça monument du cuétis et qu'on
l'a interprété comme la maison de
corporation de des artisans
métallurgistes notamment les bronziers
d'alaia ils ont une fortune historique
là encore particulière puisque dans
l'histoire naturelle plin qui est un
auteur latin là encore les mentionne il
mentionneent textuellement les artisans
bronziers d'Alesia en raison de de d'un
procédé d'argenture au plomb mais ils
appliquent du plomb autour des objets en
bronze pour leur donner l'aspect de
l'argent de fait ce monument ductis qui
est interprété qui a été interprété
jusqu'ici en tout cas comme la
corporation des artisans métallurgistes
a eu un un retentissement assez assez
particulier maintenant justement nos
fouilles nos recherches actuelles nous
amènent forcément à à se réinterroger
sur ces certitude qu'on a acquise au
début du 20e siècle et ça c'est un
procédé qui est normal quand on reprend
des fouilles anciennes en fait c'est de
de découvrir de nouvelles choses et
aussi de de de voir si ce qui a été vu
et compris au début du 20e siècle est
toujours valable à la lumière des
techniques actuelles et des savoirs
qu'on a
aujourd'hui Philip ce que tu m'as dééré
tout à l'heure c'est une mandibu de Ch
[Musique]
nonis de
faire la pluie c'est c'est un problème
pour les fouilleurs mais aussi surtout
pour le terrain on passe notre temps à
nettoyer observer mais on a besoin de
surface qui reste propre toujours et
avec la pluie on peut pas faire propre
avec la pluie en étale de la boue
partout ouais c'est le l'ennemi numéro 1
quoi à la pluie on perd en lisibilité
donc en fait quand il pleut comme ça on
jaosee toujours entre le confort des
fouilleurs évidemment parce que ils sont
pas là non plus pour s'enrumer au bout
de au bout de de jours enfin on n'est
pas en contexte professionnel donc eux
ils viennent pour se former ils viennent
pour participer au chantier donc quand
il pleut on all moi en tout cas je les
mets pas sous la pluie du coup il y a
toujours du boulot de lavage quoi oui on
a beaucoup de lavage à faire pour le
coup on est vra ou on est vraiment on
est en retard on est pas en retard mais
on sort beaucoup de matériel beaucoup de
faune comme on fouille les reste d'un
banquet ben c'est plusieurs dizaines de
kilos d'ossem qui
sortent c'est gratin ce soir c'est
gratin ce soir voilà c'est pour
récompenser les fuir vous avez toutous
ça à l'aller oui ça c'est que la
première caisse
et surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est
ça l'US le secteur et l'année de la
campagne de fouille parce que plus tard
quand ce sera inventorier ça permettra
ben aux gens qui vont étudier les EOS ou
les céramiques et cetera de savoir
exactement d'où ça vient aussi au niveau
du banquet en gros c'est une zone où il
y a plein de d'eau qui ont été jeté
c'est des EAU où on voit des traces de
découpe ou des choses comme ça mais il y
a pas de viande dessus s'ils avaient été
laissé à l'air libre il y aurait eu des
charonniardes qui seraient venus manger
dessus et on a pas de trace de
charonniar donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont
été directement dans la f intérêt est-ce
que tu sais si je me demandais ça en
fouillant si tous les EAU qu'on retrouve
dans le Banquet s correspondent à une
période assez courte ou si ça a été
utilisé pendant assez longtemps
justement c'est ce que Matthieu disait
c'est que ils sont tous sur une période
très rapprochée ils sont entre 13 avant
et 9
après une troup en fait ça fait une
grosse in vraiment un TR ils sont ils
sont bien ven forcés sur là je crois
qu'on a
pas qu' a encore des traces de recettes
il y a beaucoup de textes des Grecs qui
parlent des des recettes des repas donc
à la fois des de leur repas à eux mais
aussi des repas des Gaulois et et les
Gaulois ils mangent beaucoup de de
nourriture liquide beaucoup de bouillons
de choses comme ça où ils font tout
bouillir ensemble des des ragou viandes
ce genre de choses et et après il
mangent ça dans les banquets il y en a
qui fouillent pour la première fois à
lesésia toi d'accord ça fait déjà de
semaines que je suis là et je reste le
mois entier ça te plaît c'est trop bien
bah c'est une chance pour une première P
c'est pas rien quoi ouais c'est une
chance
parce que c'est un peu iconique entre
guillemets tout le monde conna
quoi même les gens qui connaissent pas
je leur dis oui je fais un stage à alia
cet été c'est vrai trop bien
ouais c'est cool c'est bien on est bien
installé il me semble que c'est la
maison historique entre guillemets des
fouilleurs Deia ça fait depuis des
générations qu'il viennent qui
s'installent ici pour fouiller le site
cette année j'ai fait mes 40 ans de
fouille à je suis arrivé en 1982 je
venais d'avoir le bac j'avais déjà
fouillé et un peu en quelque s je suis
plus jamais repartie sur 40 ans je me
suis jamais ennuyée parce que j'ai j'ai
analysé cherché le site absolument dans
toutes ces dimensions et ce qui est
assez passionnant c'est la continuité de
l'occupation depuis le néolithique en
fait on est on est prombaré depuis la
période néoliique on sa on a des
éléments de l'âge du pronze dont un
morceau de rempard complètement à
l'autre extrémité à la croix
Saint-Charles euh on s'est pas montrer
sur un plan où étaient ses habitats et
cetera mais on sait qu'ils étaient là il
y a des tombeau tour enfin voilà on a
cette présence depuis le le néolithique
sur le site et après les Gaulois on les
repère de façon assez ancienne là aussi
mais par des traces fugaces par un
morceau de torque cassé par une fibu
plus ancienne de vages de l'âge du
pronze encore plus ancien des choses
comme ça qui sont des un mobile qui nous
parle mais en en bruit de fond en fait
de cette présence et puis après on a
vraiment à partir des années 120 et et
80 sur la fourchette 80 50 bien plus là
on repère vraiment cette cette
occupation et maintenant on sait la
caractériser en gros la vue qu'on a ici
où on regarde cette magnifique vue là où
on voit ce qui se passe dans la plaine
qui arrive et quoi et le temps quiil
fait eux ils étaient là VO ils voyaient
ça et donc ils ont vu arriver les armées
césariennes ils ont vu arriver vers
saintjudre juste avant voà ces gens-là
qui ont habité là ils ont ils ont tout
vu de cet épisode historique versutoric
il prend le la tête d'une coalition
gauloise qui en 52 avant Jésus-Christ se
révolte face à la conquête césarienne et
décide de contrer les armées de César
Alésia euh n'intervient en fait que qu'à
un moment donné de cette année 52 avant
Jésus-Christ qu'à l'été à l'été 52 avant
Jésus-Christ c'est pas un lieu où où est
ver saint-jitorix mais c'est un lieu où
à un moment donné l'armée gauloise ou en
tout cas la coalition gauloise de
versorix se replie et autour duquel les
Romains
entame un
[Musique]
siège
c'està-dire que à partir du moment où
les Gaulois sont enfermés à l'intérieur
de d'alisia il y a si on en croit César
là encore un long moment d'attente où en
fait on attend que l'armée de secours
arrive il y a notamment un passage que
César décrit dans ses commentaires sur
La Guerre des Gaules puisque c'est la
seule source contemporaine du siège qui
soit parvenu César dit que à un moment
donné pour économiser de la nourriture
versetorix chasse de l'opidome d'Alesia
les bouches inutiles entendu les femmes
les enfants et les vieilles gars donc
tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas se battre
César dit également dans contexte que
lui ne les a pas laisser passer il
serait il serait mort quelque part en
fait sur les pentes de l'opidom
[Musique]
d'alasia
au début du siège donc quand les armées
commencent à s'installer là et puis à la
fin également une fois que l'armée de
secours est ici il y a plusieurs
batailles qui ont qui ont lieu au pied
de cette colline d'alisia au niveau des
fortifications romaines ce qui aurait
fait la différence ce serait
beaucoup la cavalerie auxiliaire
Germaine qui a été ramenée par les
Romains et puis les Romains avaient pour
eux aussi ses fortifications qui fait
que ils étaient ils étaient pas
imbattables mais en tout cas ils étaient
ils étaient prêts c'est une tactique
aussi de préparer un siège l'armée
romaine c'est une armée qui est devenue
professionnelle déjà à cette époque là
ça fait pas si longtemps que ça qu'elle
l' on est au milieu du 1er siècle avant
Jésus-Christ à l'époque de César mais ce
sont maintenant des gens qui sont
entraînés à se battre et qui savent
surtout se battre en pleine dans les
endroits où on peut se déployer
facilement donc c'est aussi des choses
qui on peut peser per dans la balance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la recherche s'est polarisée sur le
siège et sur la ville d'époque impériale
et ensuite plus récemment sur la ville
gauloise donc c'est quoi c'est plusieurs
petites maisons plusieurs alors c'est
toujours compliqué de d'arriver à à
faire les plans et à comprendre comment
tout ça fonctionne parce que tout ce que
vous voyez là sur le terrain c'est des
instantanés c'està dire c'est toutes les
époques en même temps à nous après de
comprendre quels sont les murs qui
fonctionnent avec quel niveau de sol et
quel quel retour d'angle ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est un ce qu'on appelle une
insoua donc c'est un hîlo d'habitation
et que dans cet hîlo vous avez sans
doute plusieurs logements plusieurs
habitations des cours pourquoi pas des
locaux des locaux d'artisanat parce
qu'on
estououi là on est dans de la alors les
Gaulois savent construire avec de la
pierre ça arrive aussi enfin à l'époque
gauloise à bibract par exemple il y a
plein de bâtiments en pierre qui sont
d'époque Gaulois ici c'est pas trop le
cas euh mais oui ça c'est une cave qui a
été aménagé entre le 1er et le 2e siècle
après Jésus-Christ rblayé au 3e euh et
c'est une cave qui est assez belle parce
qu'elle a un escalier carartetournant en
plus avec quoi là une une fenêtre un
sairrail ou voilà donc là c'est dans cet
état qu'on a laissé ça l'année dernière
on voit les Osem qui commence à
apparaître sachant qu'on avait déjà
enlevé une quantité assez importante
mais euh voilà on était pas tout à fait
au bout de nos surprises c'est vrai que
c'est un sacré travail surtout à
fouiller mais je va surtout faire
l'étude après c'estd que après la
fouille a la poste fouille qui dure des
mois avec l'étude de la céramique et
tout et moi je vais m'occuper des ossems
donc je pense que j'auraai une trentaine
de caisses à récupérer tuà fait des
rêves avec des oses de partout j'en fait
beaucoup dernièrement là en fouillant le
banquet ouais je je je rêve des EOS la
nuit je suis en train de les les
détourer c'est inf femme et et là là tu
as déjà un estimatif du nombre de de
bêtes du banquet alors c'est difficile à
estimer on va essayer de restituer la
population initiale donc c'est le nombre
minimal d'individus par exemple pour la
céramique ça peut être le nombre de ans
c'est c'estz pratique pour savoir le
nombre de de vases qu'il y avait pour
les EOS bah par exemple les crânes c'est
très pratique là il y a plusieurs crânes
donc je sais qu'il y a au moins je crois
SEP crânes de por donc au moins C
individ
C crânes de bœuf et cetera puis après je
vais regarder s'il y a par exemple h
humérus gauche de cheval je sais qu' au
moins chevaux qui sont impliqués dans
dans ce banquet donc il mange du cheval
il mange quoi euh oui il y a des traces
de découpe de sur les
chevaux j'étais pas trop sûr avant mais
j'en ai trouvé sur des tibias des tibias
de chevaux donc vraiment des traces de
décarnisation de prélèvement de de la
viande parce que trace de découpe ne pas
forcément dire consommation de l'animal
ça peut être récupération de la matière
osseuse des tendons au niveau des bas de
pattes de la peau et puis de l'os en
soit ils font beaucoup de tabletteries
mais là non j'ai vraiment des traces de
prélèvement de la de la chair c'est une
pratique gauloise consommation de cheval
c'est à tester chez les Gaulois et qui
ça disparaît avec les Romains mais là on
est un contexte du coup qui est au
moment de la romanisation donc il y a du
matériel romain on est chez les Romains
enfin chez les Gal romains mais c'est
encore culturellement c'est Gaulois donc
et peut-être
on cherche la consommation du chien
aussi mais ça je je suis pas encore
sûr ça
va donc ici c'est une cuisine donc là
pour le coup c'est un aménagement qui
est relativement récent puisque ça date
du 2e siècle après Jésus-Christ et donc
c'est voilà une petite cuisine on a
l'empreinte de la table à feu qu'on
aperçoit là contre le mur ça fait un
espèce de rectangle comme ça qui est
plaqué contre le mur et dans la coupe ce
qu'on voit c'est une petite couche noire
qui correspond au sol originel de la
cuisine là vous voyez des trous dans la
cuisine et justement les trous dans la
cuisine c'est des foses gauloises qui
ont été entaillé dans le terrain naturel
donc là c'est plus la cuisine c'est sous
la cuisine et et des fosses ça sert à
quoi bah ça peut avoir différentes
fonctions soit c'est des fauxes on
rejette des choses soit c'est des fauxes
dans lesquelles on met des poteaux pour
pour pour construire des des bâtiments
et dans la cuisine vous avez retrouvé de
la céramique comment comment à part le
la l'endroit où il y a un foyer à quoi
on voit que c'est cuisine parce qu'on a
trouvé que des cruches et des mortiers
c'està-dire de la vaisselle de
préparation culinaire en fait le
matériel qu'on trouve à l'intérieur va
va nous dire de
quand de quand cette fausse date et à
quoi elle
correspond alors c'est c'est notre
céramolog qui va déterminer tout ça qui
va arriver dans pas si longtemps
d'ailleurs
mais bon c'est pas moderne si ça peut te
rassurer c'est pas Gaulois non plus
pasis d'acc ça c'est de la
terraanigra terranigra donc une
céramique à pâte noire comme ça qui a
les tranches à pâte grise pouroi ce
serait pas c'est pas Go parce que ça la
terranigra ça arrive surtout à partir de
l'époque augustienne il y en a dans le
Banquet c'est ça qui nous fait dater le
banquet voilà peut-être que ça date de
la même époque que le banquet
d'ailleurs on
verra toi tu es spécialiste de la
céramique notamment c'est ça oui ok et
est-ce qu'il y a une une espèce de
rupture assez franche entre euh la
céramique environnante avant et après la
bataille non c'est ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs avec la céramique qui est
dans le Banquet c'est qu'on a à la fois
de la céramique très caractéristique des
des Gaulois qui sont des pets à cuir je
sais pas si j'ai
des des choses comme ça des des pots à
cuir on en a plusieurs
enfin voilà des choses très
caractéristiques des des Gaulois mélangé
avec des choses très caractéristiques
des qui qui arrive au moment
de avec les Romains notamment une
céramique qui s'appelle la terraanigra
des petites assiette voilà qui date de
la charnière du du 1er siècle mélangé
avec du mobilier parfaitement Gaulois
par ailleurs donc du coup il y a deux
solutions soit c'est un mange de
mobilier soit pendant encore assez
longtemps
on a fabriqué la céramique culinaire et
un certain nombre de céramique de table
à
l'ancienne et puis de toute façon
l'archéologie nous montre que voilà il y
a pas de rupture entre l'époque de
l'opidome Gaulois et l'époque romaine
c'estàdire que cette ville cette
occupation gauloise elle continue à
exister elle continue à perdurer alisia
s'intègre petit à petit dans un empire
romain qui s'administre on utilise le
terme de romanisation en général pour
pour simplifier un peu ce concept on a
tendance à essayer de préciser les
choses plutôt que de dire vous voyez que
j'ai essayé d'éviter de dire àésias
romanise parce que c'est un peu
simpliste de se dire qu'alisia d'un coup
se romanise en fait se romanise ça veut
dire ça implique plusieurs domaines ça
implique la langue ça implique la
religion ça implique l'architecture ça
implique beaucoup de choses en fait mais
ce que montre nos fouilles actuelles par
exemple c'est que à l'époque augustéenne
donc au changement d'air si vous voulez
on continue à faire par exemple des
banquets comme on s'attendrait à les
retrouver dans des niveaux
archéologiques purement gaois avec des
enfors à vin avec bah des grands dépôts
d'osmo animaux qui sont qui sont
découpés qui sont consommés et avec des
espèces notamment le cheval qui sont
consommés par les Gaulois mais sur
lesquels il y a des tabou alimentaires
he les Romains ne consomment pas le
cheval mais ici à alisia et c'est
peut-être le cas ailleurs même à
l'époque romaine on continue à consommer
du cheval le plus probable c'est que ce
soit un seul banquet parce que tout est
très homogène que ce soit les l'état de
conservation tout ce qu'on trouve les
niveaux archéologiques la vaisselle
qu'il y a à l'intérieur les objets
métalliques qui sont piégés les quelques
objets métalliques qui sont piégés dans
tout ça tout ça est très homogène et il
y a rien qui nous laisse penser à
l'existence de plusieurs épisodes de
banquets différents c'est un grand repas
probablement public parce que ça fait
quand même beaucoup de viande pour un
contexte privé mais tout ça a été rejeté
dans dans dans une grande fausse à
l'époque
augustienne
[Musique]
ag
c'est une tache sombre continue qui fait
un cercle de 10 m de diamètre on se rend
compte qu'il y a des petits fragments de
céramique des petits morceaux de silex
donc on est sur un vrai aménagement qui
est lié à la main de l'homme c'est pas
c'est pas du tout naturel cette
structure correspond en fait au seul
vestige qui conservé d'un d'un petit
tumulus et depuis le début on ne fouille
que des vestiges d'habitat donc des
bâtiments des fosses tout ce qui est lié
vraiment à une vie quotidienne et le
fait d'avoir une une architecture
funéraire pas si loin que ça de
l'habitat ça pose beaucoup de questions
on peut imaginer du coup il y en a
d'autres ça c an ouais il y a une grande
chance peut-être que ça se poursuit dans
le champ d'un côté peut-être que ça se
poursuit
derrière